♪♪
>>> THAT IS A LOT OF CANDIDATES
UP ON THAT WALL FOR CHICAGO
MAYOR.
CHICAGO, AS I WAS TAUGHT TO SAY.
TODAY'S ELECTION DAY.
CHICAGO MAYORAL PRIMARY, HOT
LEST CONTESTED PLAYER.
LORI LIGHTFOOT IS FIGHTING FOR
SUR VIECHL.
SHE DEFIED EXPECTATIONS FUR
YEARS AGO BECOMING THE FIRST
BLACK WOMAN AND OPENLY GAY
PERSON TO BECOME CHICAGO MAYOR.
DAVID AXLEROD, IT'S WHERE WE
MET, IN 2003.
>> IT IS, INDEED, YES.
HEY, GUYS.
>> BASICALLY, GOOD MORNING.
WHAT IS THE WEATHER LIKE THERE?
OH, YOU ARE IN PENNSYLVANIA.
>> PENNSYLVANIA.
BUT IT'S NICE A CHICAGO.
I'M TOLD IT'S NICE IN CHICAGO
TODAY.
GOOD VOTING WEATHER.
I HOPE EVERYBODY TAKES ADVANTAGE
OF IT.
>> YEAH, THAT'S WHY I'M ASKING
BECAUSE THAT MEANS USUALLY
BETTER WEATHER MEANS BIGGER
TURNOUT.
IT LOOKS LIKE IT COULD BE A
RUNOFF IN APRIL.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF LORI
LIGHTFOOT'S CHANCES OF BEING ONE
OF THE TOP TWO CONTENDERS AND
ADVANCE, TO ADVANCE, I SHOULD
SAY, TO THAT RUNOFF?
>> WELL, THAT IS THE BIG
QUESTION OF THE DAY, DON.
SEEMS PRETTY CLEAR ONE OF HER
OPPONENTS, PAUL VALLAS, WILL
FINISH FIRST IN THE RUNOFF -- IN
THIS PRIMARY, AND HE WILL MOVE
ON TO THE RUNOFF.
THE BIG QUESTION IS, WHO WILL
JOIN HIM IN THAT RUNOFF?
IT'S NOT CERTAIN THAT THE
INCUMBENT MAYOR OF THE CITY,
LORI LIGHTFOOT, WILL BE ONE OF
THOSE TWO.
SHE IS IN A VERY PITCHED BATTLE
WITH A COUPLE OF OTHER
CANDIDATES.
BRANDON JOHNSON, WHO IS A COUNTY
COMMISSIONER, BACKED BY THE
LOCAL TEACHERS UNION.
AND CONGRESSMAN CHUY GARCIA, WHO
RAN LAST TIME.
ONE OF THOSE THROW IS LIKELY TO
BE IN THE RUNOFF.
IT MAY NOT BE THE MAYOR.
WE'LL HAVE TO WAIT AND SEE.
AND HERE IS THE HITCH.
WE MAY NOT KNOW FOR WEEKS THIS
COULD BE VERY, VERY CLOSE FOR
SECOND PLACE.
IF IT IS, THEY MAY HAVE TO WAIT
FOR ALL OF THE ABSENTEE -- ALL
IN WRITE-IN BALLOTS, I SHOULD
SAY, TO ARRIVE.
THERE IS A MARCH 14th DEADLINE
FOR THAT IF IT'S POSTED BY
ELECTION DAY.
SO WE'LL SEE.
THERE COULD BE A RECOUNT FOR
THAT SECOND SPOT.
SO APRIL 4th IS THE GENERAL.
HALF THAT TIME MAY BE SPENT
FIGURING OUT WHO THE CANDIDATES
ARE GOING TO BE.
>> YEAH.
THERE IS A REAL CHANCE OF HER
BEING SHUT OUT.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS AS WE
TRACK THAT.
DAVID, WHILE WE HAVE YOU HERE,
GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS'S NEW BOOK
COMES OUT SOMETHING I THOUGHT W
INTERESTING, HE WRITES, I DON'T
THINK REPUBLICAN PRIMARY VOTER
ARES SHEEP WHO FOLLOW AN
ENDORSEMENT FROM A POLITICIAN
THEY LIKE WITHOUT INDIVIDUAL
ANALYSIS, DOWNPLAYING A
PARTICULAR ENDORSEMENT THAT HE
GOT.
DID YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> WELL, I THINK HE IS REWRITING
HISTORY A LITTLE BIT.
PEOPLE IN FLORIDA I THINK
REMEMBER HOW INSTRUMENTAL THE
TRUMP ENDORSEMENT WAS AT THE
TIME FOR DeSANTIS.
TRUMP IS NOT WRONG ABOUT THAT.
WE HAVE SEEN EXAMPLES IN
REPUBLICAN PRIMARIES WHERE
TRUMP'S ENDORSEMENT HAS BEEN
MEANINGFUL.
I THINK DeSANTIS, HE WANTS TO
REWRITE HIS ORIGIN STORY HERE IN
FLORIDA POLITICS AND NATIONAL
POLITICS, BUT I'LL TELL YOU,
GUYS, WHAT IS AMAZING TO ME IS
THE BRAZENNESS WITH WHICH THIS
GUY IS RUNNING HIS NON-CAMPAIGN
SCLSH CAMPAIGN.
HE CAME INTO CHICAGO, JUST WAS
IN CHICAGO TALKING TO THE
FRATERNAL ORDER OF POLICE THERE,
MAKING A NATIONAL TOUR AROUND
THE ISSUE OF PELOTONnd THE GUISE
GUISE OF TRYING TO ATTRACT
POLICE TO COME TO FLORIDA.
HE HAS A BOOK TOUR, FLORIDA'S
BLUEPRINT FOR AMERICA'S REVIVAL.
THIS IS ABOUT AS SUBTLE AS A
SCREEN TORE ON A SUBMARINE.
HE IS NOT GOING TO ANNOUNCE
UNTIL JUNE.
>> SAYING HE IS NOT RUNNING,
DAVID?
>> YEAH, RIGHT.
WHAT IS INTERESTING HE IS IN A
POSITION WHERE HE IS NOT A
CANDIDATE.
SO THERE ARE CERTAIN LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS HE DOESN'T HAVE TO
ABIDE TO.
AND HE IS ALSO NOT AS MUCH OF A
TARGET BECAUSE HE IS NOT AN
ACTIVE CANDIDATE.
YES, HE IS CLEARLY ACTIVELY
CAMPAIGNSING AND IT WILL BE
INTERESTING TO SEE HOW LONG
PEOPLE TAKE A HANDS-OFF POSTURE
TOWARDS HIM IN THIS RACE.
>> PART OF THAT CAMPAIGNING I
FIND SO NON-CAMPAIGNING
CAMPAIGNING IS THE CULTURE WAR
ELEMENT.
VIS-A-VIS DISNEY, IT COLLIDES
WITH THE ROLE OF GOVERNMENT AND
WHAT THE REPUBLICAN STANDARDS
FOR, BIG GOVERNMENT OR LIMITED
GOVERNMENT.
YESTERDAY WHEN HE SIGNED THE
BILL THAT GIVES CONTROL OVER THE
LAND DISNEY IS ON IN FLORIDA AND
NAMES -- HE GETS IN NAME HIS OWN
BOARD MEMBERS NOW, THIS IS WHAT
HE SAID.
TODAY THE CORPORATE KINGDOM
COMES TO TAN END.
THERE IS A NEW SHERIFF IN END,
ACCOUNTABILITY WILL BE THE ORDER
OF THE DAY.
I AM SO STRUCK BY THAT MARKED
CHANGE IN PHILOSOPHY IN TERMS OF
THE ROLE OF GOVERNMENT AND
CORPORATIONS.
>> YOU'RE SO RATE.
RON DeSANTIS WHEN HE BEGAN IN
POLITICS AND HE WROTE A BOOK
AROUND THESE PRINCIPLES WAS A
SMALL GOVERNMENT LIBERTARIAN.
NOW HE IS A KIND OF RIGHT-WING
AUTHORITARIAN IN THE SENSE THAT,
YOU KNOW, IF YOU DISAGREE WITH
HIM AS A CORPORATION HE IS GOING
TO COME AFTER YOU WITH THE POWER
OF THE STATE AND THAT IS GOING
TO CREATE A LOT OF DEBATE WITHIN
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY, I THINK.
BUT HE IS REVELING IN THE
CULTURE WAR ELEMENTS OF THIS, AS
YOU SAY, HE BELIEVES THAT'S HIS
TICKET TO GETTING SOME OF THOSE
TRUMP VOTES.
I ALWAYS SAY, YOU KNOW, THE
HOPE -- THE HOPE OF HIS
SUPPORTERS THAT HE WILL BE KIND
OF TRANSITION DRUG FOR TRUMP
SUPPORTERS WHO WANT TO KICK THE
HABIT OF TRUMP, HE GIVES YOU THE
CULTURE WAR HIGH BUT MAY NOT BE
AS DANGEROUS TO YOUR POLITICAL
HEALTH.
BUT HE CERTAINLY ISN'T THE
LIBERTARIAN THAT HE PURPORTED TO
BE.
HIS BOOK IS THE COURAGE TO BE
FREE, BUT IF YOU'RE A WOMAN WHO
NEEDS AN ABORTION IN FLORIDA, IF
YOU'RE, YOU KNOW, A CORPORATION
WHO EXPRESSES ITSELF ON A PUBLIC
ISSUE, YOU KNOW, IF YOU'RE THE
PARENT OF, YOU KNOW, IF YOU ARE
A GAY PARENTS IN FLORIDA, THERE
ARE A RANGE OF PEOPLE WHO DON'T
FEEL AS FREE IN FLORIDA BECAUSE
OF THE KIND